salut romain ça va non je crois que la
voir l'appendicite
ah merde pas mal à votre nom non pas que
la fia gt envie de vomir
non tu as quoi exactement j'ai avalé mon
chewing-gum sans faire exprès
[Musique]
l'appendicite
je connaissais même si ça se perd
beaucoup moins qu'avant je suis sûr que
vous connaissez et je suis sûr que vous
avez entendu dire que si on avale ce
chewing gum
on risque de la voir d'appendicite est
ce que c'est vrai ça ça fait alors on va
commencer par le début l'appendice c'est
un petit tuyau en tube sac de quelques
centimètres de long de quelques
millimètres de diamètre qui est accroché
à la première partie du colon qu'on
appelle le caecum et qui se trouve là
juste en bas à droite
c'est une structure vestiges yal c'est à
dire le vestige d'un organe dont
l'utilité chez les êtres humains a
diminué au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution
alors attention on s'est quand même qui
produit des anticorps et que c'est une
sorte de réservoir à flore intestinale
de secours donc il n'est pas
complètement inutile mais il est pas du
tout indispensable non plus on vit très
bien sans
bon et alors l'appendicite la plupart du
temps ce qui se passe c'est que le petit
tuyau is bush
et comme c'est un cul de sac les
bactéries se développent à l'intérieur
et ça s'enflamme ça sent faict ça gonfle
ça fait mal ça donne de la fièvre etc
et c'est considéré comme une urgence
parce qu'il faut retirer l'appendice
avant que ça s'aggrave et donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils bouchent ce petit machin et l'art
en général ce qu'il bouge c'est du caca
faut dire qu'il a pas mal dans le
secteur dans certains cas ça peut aussi
être des résidus d'alimentation genre
des pétales ce oui ça peut aussi être un
parasite jean inverse mais tout ça c'est
très rare et donc ce qu'on raconte c'est
que si on avale ses chewing gum ils
peuvent faire un bouchon et provoquer
une appendicite et bah c'est faux pour
comprendre pourquoi c'est faux il faut
savoir ce que deviennent les chewing gum
canton les avale les chewing gum ça fait
partie des matières non digestibles
c'est à dire que les sucres de l'estomac
qui n'arrive pas à les 10
du coup il reste beaucoup plus longtemps
dans l'estomac et ils mettent beaucoup
plus de temps à faire tout le trajet le
long du tube digestif mais pas plusieurs
années un juste quelques heures de plus
que d'habitude
donc les chewing gum comme les autres
matières non digestibles il reste plus
longtemps dans le tube digestif mais ils
finissent par sortir juste ils
ressortent tel quel sans boucher
l'appendice attention ça veut pas dire
que c'est complètement impossible ça
veut juste dire que c'est pas une cause
d'appendicite connu on n'a pas retrouvé
de chewing gum dans les appendices des
gens qu'on a opéré ou tant qu'on y est
ça reste pas sept ans dans l'estomac
comme on peut l'entendre dire et ça ne
colle pas les parois non plus par contre
ce qui a été décrit par des médecins
c'est des cas d'occlusion intestinale
chez des enfants chez qui on l'a
retrouvé des masses de chewing gum
bloqués dans le rectum et m'a même un
qui parle de masse multicolores c'est
joli mais ça bouge au rectum après bon
faut savoir que les enfants en question
il avalait 5 à 7 chewing gum tous les
jours donc ça reste très rare mais ça
existe c'est possible le mieux dans le
doute c'est quand même ne pas les avaler
mais bon si vous en allez en temps en
temps et a pas de souci et pour finir
sur une note positive sachez que
certaines études suggèrent que le fait
de mâcher du chewing-gum après une
opération
cela pourrait accélérer le retour du
transit intestinal faut juste ma chérie
globalement mâchouiller si vous voulez
mais n'allez pas de chou ne voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui si vous poser
d'autres questions de ce genre
envoyez les moi à question dtc @ gmail
point com
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]